joining me now is Senator Tommy tuille
member of the Senate armed services
committee Senator I know you saw this on
Capitol Hill um they really do I think
think we're that stupid tying Aid to
Israel to this boondoggle amount in
Ukraine given just what we learned in
This Time Magazine investigation well
you got it right Laura clown show that's
exactly what it is on on the hill that
they look for any kind of Crisis to to
make money borrow money you know we're
printing over $100,000 a minute right
now just to pay for all this stuff we
don't have the money we're baring money
from China uh you know the people that
were actually supposed to be preparing
War for in the near future it's an
absolute clown show now John Kirby is
outraged that anyone in the GOP would
interfere with the administration's
desire to send this money overseas watch
this Senator demanding offsets for core
National Security means needs like
supporting Israel and defending Ukraine
is a break with the nor normal
bipartisan process that could have
devastating implications for our safety
and for our national security interest
overseas there shouldn't be any
political games played here with our
national
security Senator uh do the Democrats
want apparently no debate on this it's
just a shame the likes of you and
Senator Holly and um others shame you
into supporting Ukraine and if you don't
I guess you're no better than Hamas well
they think we should bite on any
anything that they throw out there it it
it's really a shame they don't do
anything for the American taxpayer all
the money is going out of the country uh
we're all looking at Ukraine we're
looking at Israel now we've got to do
something at the border and that's what
we should do as Republicans stand up and
say listen we we're all for Israel and
what what a travesty that was but unless
they do something for the American
people at the border because we're in
trouble down there if we don't do
something uh you don't get anything
we're going to get into that with a
governor with a lieutenant governor of
of Texas in just a moment I couldn't
agree more um Mitch McConnell is really
unhappy with you senator for holding up
these um nominations of course the
nominations could all be voted on the
most important ones in due course um
McConnell took a shot at you today I
want to give you a chance to
respond I said this is a bad idea quite
a while
ago I still think it's a bad idea I have
been among those trying to convince
Senator tuberville to uh Express his
opposition some the way by people who
actually make policy as opposed to U our
military Heroes who are sworn to stay
out of
politics Senator um apparently now
you're against military Heroes because
you believe actually that there should
be a normal course of nominations
especially when they're pushing uh the
abortion issue and the military turning
it into a social engineering event I'm
all for the military and we're in a
tough time right right now cuz our
military is struggling to actually put a
put put a group together whether it's
Army Navy Air Force uh I don't work for
Senator McConnell you know I like him
fine I work for the people of Alabama
and the taxpayers of this country uh I
thought we're pro-life I am and we're
going to fight that I do not like memos
from the White House telling us to do
our job that don't worry about voting on
this law we're going to pass it for you
I don't like that we should do it we
should have a voice for the American
people in the Senate on the senate floor
about this
uh I'm not changing my mind uh I'm
tomorrow actually putting some nominees
on the floor myself to get them
confirmed cuz Chuck schimmer won't do it
uh if we got to do his job for him
that's fine well that's where the rubber
meets the road if they decide no we
don't want to vote on these they just
want the political issue for next year
correct exactly exactly they just want
they want some kind of uh fodder to be
able to use against us but we're
actually fighting for the American
people in our country when you watched
uh Austin and and blinkin up there on
the hill today do you think they have a
clue as to what's going going on in
Ukraine looks like a rerun it looks like
every time they come into a hearing
they're always doing the same thing
they're very poetic and how they talk
and what they say but they talk in
rhythms and Rhymes they don't give you
any kind of substance uh you know
infrastructure in Ukraine and and
essentially a green New Deal for Ukraine
that's exact that's what he was
essentially you know describing there
well you remember President Biden said
our number one crisis is climate change
and it's not Israel it's not the Middle
East it's not Ukraine uh the these
people have no clue what they're doing
we better get back to worrying about the
problems of this country first we're
we're declining as a nation and if we
don't make our country stronger and
stronger we're going to have huge
problems outside our borders peace
through strength that's what ran said we
need the strength for Senator great to
see you thank you hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else